Afghanistan's capital was thrown into
chaos overnight by one of its worst
terror attacks in years a huge suicide
car bomb killed at least 80 people and
wounded at least 350 more the explosion
was just outside an area known for its
intense security a large number of
Western embassies are in that section of
Kabul
so is Afghanistan's presidential palace
but officials say they do not know what
the Bombers target was Deborah pata is
in London with new developments Deborah
good morning good morning today's loss
not only resulted in massive casualties
it's also a significant security breach
as the suicide bomber managed to
detonate the explosives at the
checkpoint to the Green Zone one of the
most secure areas in the Afghan capital
in a country that is so weary of war
it's hard to imagine things
deteriorating further but today that
happened when an explosion tore through
the heart of the Capitol and for the
families of the dozens killed and the
hundreds injured this was the worst of
days
the explosion was timed for maximum
effect rush hour traffic in Kabul when
the roads are packed with early morning
commuters the location equally strategic
at the edge of one of the most highly
secured areas of the capital its
diplomatic quarters and the result
devastating ambulances frantically
ferried the wounded mostly civilians to
hospitals in the area a never ending
line of horror Wall Street Journal
reporter Jessica Donati was there and
everything all the glass shattered I
came down to check on the staff and I
staff were all terrorized the leading
ladies were screaming both the Taliban
and Isis have been launching one bold
attack after another in recent
this despite the fact that the US and
its NATO allies have been fighting
alongside Afghan troops for 16 years now
it's costing America more than 3 billion
dollars a month to keep just over 8
thousand troops in Afghanistan a far cry
from the about 100,000 troops of 6 years
ago the Pentagon wants to reverse this
earlier this year America's top
commander in Afghanistan John Nicholson
told the Senate Armed Forces committee
that he needed thousands more troops in
your overall commander's assessment are
we winning or losing mr. Chairman I
believe we're in a stalemate the Taliban
has denied any involvement in this
attack and so far there has been no
official claim of responsibility from
any other extremist group Gail Thank You
Deborah